what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and everything
mcu and 2021 was a pretty good marvel
year we got spider-man away home
shang-chi eternals black widow marvel
studios and disney kicked off the marvel
studios disney plus shows with one
division then we got a lot of other
really awesome shows and this was great
especially since we were coming out of
2020 where we didn't get anything but
now 2021 is over and we are in 2022 and
we have a lot ahead of us when it comes
to marvel in fact there are 11 projects
coming this year from marvel now there
has been a lot of mix-ups to the lineup
to the schedule it's been delayed a
couple of times unfortunately thanks to
kovid and that still might continue to
happen but right now i want to talk
about the 11 projects coming from marvel
that are going to be happening this year
hopefully nothing changes to the
schedule again fingers crossed and there
are also two bonus projects that still
could be happening in 2022 so it is
possible that we could get 13 projects
in 2022 and of course like always i'll
break it all down for you and if you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
on everything marvel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos now to kick off marvel for
2022 we get moon knight and i think this
is a really good way to start off the
year with marvel because it's going to
be a pretty different project than we're
used to it's going to be more of a like
a daredevil feel gritty violent dark
which i think a lot of people are
actually really excited to see i
personally am as well i wonder what that
says about me but i am and this is kind
of going to kickstart that darker more
werewolfy vampire-ish type of style for
the mcu and they're going to keep that
rolling in april with morbius now this
isn't an mcu film but we do know that it
might connect to it somehow but
regardless it still is a marvel project
and we could be getting another
spider-man in this film we have seen a
spider-man on the wall in the trailer we
have seen some photos of the daily
beagle talking about spider-man so
clearly he is in this universe somehow
but even if he wasn't morbius does look
like a genuinely good movie that i am
excited to see then kicking off the next
month the film that everybody is waiting
for and talking about right now doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness now
coming out of spider-man no way home so
much is expected of this movie
especially since it's exploring the
multiverse i keep saying it but anything
can literally happen doctor strange has
already stated in spider-man knowing
home there are infinite amounts of
universes out there alternate universes
which means anything could happen they
could literally go into the old fox
universes they've already brought back
old characters and spiderman no way home
wants to stop them from doing it again
and we assume they're going to be
exploring more than a handful of
universes so maybe we see even more old
characters maybe we see some new
characters there's a lot happening in
2022 with marvel but i think i am most
excited for multiverse of madness now
next up we actually don't have an exact
release date for yet but the she-hulk
series and this looks like it's going to
be a pretty fun series we have tatiana
mislady playing she-hulk's last jennifer
walters her cousin bruce banner is also
going to be in the series and mark
ruffalo of course is returning to play
him and it sounds like marvel has more
plans for the hulk mark ruffalo's hulk
in the mcu so perhaps this could be a
setup for the next hulk film and of
course abomination is coming back we
kind of already saw him in chongqing the
legend of the ten rings will he be a
villain or a hero or an anti-hero or
what in she-hulk we're not sure yet but
if i had to put this release somewhere i
would probably say it's going to come
around may or june just because there's
a gap there and i think they would want
to release miss marvel towards the
latter half of the year because the
marvels is going to come up and they
probably want them somewhat close
together but then we get in july thor
love and thunder and i know i said i was
really excited for doctor strange too
and i really am but thor love and
thunder i think is also going to be
phenomenal russell crowe is going to be
in the movie as zeus christian bale is
going to be in the movie as gore the
godbutcher natalie portman is returning
as jane foster and she's going to be
picking up the mantle of thor not taking
the place of arthor but a different
version of thor and she'll be wielding a
minded mjolnir and chris hemsworth said
that he is in the best shape of his life
that he's ever been for thor and judging
by some of the pictures that he has
shared on his instagram that is 100 true
and it looks like we're going to be
seeing the best version of thor and
taika watiti who of course directed thor
ragnarok one of my favorite mcu movies
has said that this movie is going to be
even better than the last and it's going
to be insane so i'm really really
excited for july we then have two marvel
disney plus shows that we don't really
know when they're going to come out
those two are miss marvel and the i am
groot show now since october through
december is pretty full already with
some marvel movies and projects coming
out we could probably put these two
airing on disney plus somewhere between
july and september they are all stated
to be coming out in 2022 and that seems
to be kind of the only time period where
they could go and again they probably
want miss marvel to come out somewhat
close to 2023 when we're getting the
marvels and i think everybody is excited
for the im groot special but october
through december like i said is full in
october we have across the spiderverse
part one and although this isn't an mcu
project it sure does look like the
possibility of tom holland spider-man
showing up could actually happen we're
not expecting it but tom holland has
played a little bit coy when he's been
asked about it and even if he's not the
continuation of into the spiderverse a
film that really a ton of people loved
is just so exciting to think about miles
morales gwen stacy peter parker and a
whole bunch of other spider-man on
screen so that's coming out on october
7th and then in october we have the
werewolf by night halloween special
coming to disney plus this doesn't have
an official release date yet but since
it's going to be a halloween special we
obviously assume that it's going to be
in october not much is really known
about the series at this point in time
however in the moon night trailer we do
see moon knight beating the crap out of
werewolf by night so werewolf by night
will have been introduced to the mcu
before the halloween special comes out
and i'm not really sure what to expect
from the series but i do like the more
spooky side of the mcu so i'm excited
for it and then of course in november we
have black panther 2 wakanda forever now
there's a ton of speculation going on
right now about this movie now of course
some of this won't come true but there's
talks about dr doom showing up perhaps
he wants some vibranium and knows that
wakanda has it neymar the submariner's
showing up because of some casting calls
that marvel studio put out and of course
if you consider the history between
wakanda and atlantis they don't get
along they are at war with each other
most of the time so it would be pretty
great to see neymar pop up but the big
question of course about black panther 2
is who is going to be the new black
panther marvel studios has already
stated they're not recasting t'challa
but that doesn't mean that they're not
going to get a new black panther it
could just be a different character who
takes on the mantle could it be suri
could it be okay could it be in baku we
don't really know but i'm excited to see
what marvel studios comes up with
especially after the tragic passing of
chadwick boseman and to top the year off
in december we have the guardians of the
galaxy holiday special and james gunn
has said that this special is kind of
going to fill in the gap between what
happens with the guardians of the galaxy
and thor and guardians of the galaxy vol
3. so this is going to be important and
of course just anything with the
guardians of the galaxy i'll watch
because i love them now this is all that
we know so far about 2022 however there
is a possibility that marvel could
include two more projects and those two
projects are marvel's what if season 2
and secret invasion we don't have
release dates for these two right now
but secret invasion seems like it should
come out before the marvels which is
captain marvel 2 which comes out in
february of 2023 so if it does need to
come out before the marvels it will
probably come out in 2022 this year and
as for marvel's what if we have no idea
when they're planning to release season
2 it could be in 2022 but right now i
would expect it for 2023 but regardless
if nothing changes at all we have 11
marvel projects coming out in 2022. this
is so much more than the three or four
that would come out every year that
we've gotten in the past so it is a
great time to be a marvel fan let me
know which project you are most excited
about in the comments down below again
for me i think it's doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness tied with thor
love and thunder but let me know yours
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof